what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and this is a complicated
time
if you're an mha fan on the one hand the
story is evolving in new and exciting
ways
but on the other hand the mha that we
knew when the series first began
is pretty much dead the hero society has
all but collapsed
a new age of chaos has replaced the
previous
age of peace and it seems like the
bokudo hero manga
is only going to get darker from here
personally i think that's a good thing
the story is maturing and so are all the
characters that we love
but at the same time the story has been
forced to give up a lot of the
fun-loving innocence that it once had
there is a lot to talk about right now
things will never be the same again
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave that like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
i often get people telling me that they
forgot to subscribe or they forgot to
hit the bell
and then they miss a ton of my videos if
you want to avoid that the best thing
you can do
is to take the time to subscribe hit the
bell and then select that option that
says
all finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so the
previous chapter featured hawks's tragic
backstory
i plan to make an entire video dedicated
to hawks so i won't talk much about it
here
but the rest of the chapter focused on
the fact that best genius
has a freaking batmobile oh and we also
learned how best genus was able to trick
dobby into thinking he was dead
the heroes used a procedure to induce a
death-like state within genus
a procedure inspired by the nomu
themselves
this was obviously a massive risk but
ultimately it paid off
if the heroes hadn't launched those
raids when they did
and if shigaraki had been allowed to
complete his procedure then the
situation would have been even worse
than it is now
although as we soon see the situation is
still quite bad
the other big focus of the previous
chapter is very relevant to this chapter
and that is the fact that in the
aftermath of the raids and the multiple
prison breaks
the hero society is pretty much
collapsing before
our eyes the cops and the heroes have
their hands full with all the escaped
convicts
and that has led to a lot more villain
activity all over japan
as lesser villains take advantage of all
the chaos
and cash in and as the chaos spreads
the people of japan continue to lose
their faith in both the heroes
and the police this point is really
driven home in the latest chapter
chapter 300 as the entire hero society
descends
into outright panic by the way can you
believe that mha is already at 300
chapters the time really flew by anyway
all the news about the escaped villains
and the monstrous no move roaming around
japan have terrified the public
and beyond just news and rumors the
escaped villains
and other villains have been rampaging
throughout the country and the heroes
just haven't been able to keep up
we see one particular incident in
shinjuku as the cider house gang that
escaped from xi'an prison starts
terrorizing a neighborhood
and with no police or heroes around the
civilians are forced to take up arms and
fight the villains
on their own the entire neighborhood is
soon in ruins
and when washu finally does arrive he is
actually attacked and ridiculed by the
people of the neighborhood for showing
up so late
with all this unprecedented stress and
chaos
some heroes have simply lost their nerve
and they decided to hang up their hero
capes for good
for example the number 9 pro hero and a
bunch of other heroes decided to
suddenly retire
and this has made the entire situation
even worse as i mentioned earlier
the heroes and law enforcement are
already understaffed
and now that a bunch of heroes have
retired in the middle of a villain
crisis
things are only going to get harder for
the heroes who are still in the game
you can't necessarily blame these heroes
who retired
for doing what they did we saw that one
hero back in chapter 296
who just couldn't handle the pressure
and the trauma of the aftermath
in jakku so he decided that he just
can't be a hero
any longer something similar probably
happened to the other heroes who decided
to retire
the truth is that many people simply
cannot handle that extreme
level of stress and pressure up to this
point in the story
the hero society existed in a state of
relative peace and prosperity for many
years
so the actual job of being a hero was a
mostly glamorous
and highly sought after position but now
that the piece has collapsed and chaos
has arrived
what it means to be a hero has changed
completely
it is no longer enough for heroes to
just be flashy celebrities who save
people from accidents
and natural disasters in this new
darker era heroes must be warriors who
are willing to sacrifice their very
lives
in battle against ruthless overpowered
villains
not everyone is cut out for that type of
life
and i think that's something that we can
all understand as human beings
but still all of these sudden hero
retirements were not well received by
the wider public
the public sees this as a betrayal these
heroes were fine
receiving all that money and fame that
comes with being a hero when things were
good
but now that things are bad and the
people need heroes more than ever
these particular heroes decided to just
give up and call it quits
unsurprisingly this turn of events has
caused the people of japan to lose
even more confidence in the entire
heroes system and their confidence was
already pretty low to begin with
the chapter then shows none other than
the hero killer stain
just walking around town and recovering
his old weapons
which is on one level very creepy since
stain is a major villain
and now he's just walking around free
but on the other hand
i love staying as a character and i
actually hope that this means that we'll
be seeing more of him
in the future to be honest i wouldn't be
surprised if stain becomes more of a
hero than a villain
from now on remember that stain always
hated the hero society because of how
fake
the hero profession had become but now
that the hero society has pretty much
collapsed and the so-called
fake heroes are all retiring stain might
actually decide that the real threat are
no longer the fake heroes
but rather the villains themselves it
will be very interesting to see where
stain goes from here
but my prediction is that he'll side
with the heroes at least
to some extent although he will of
course stay independent and do his own
thing
stain is still a wanted criminal after
all so it's not like he's gonna go apply
for a hero license
or anything along those lines meanwhile
a lot of the blame for what's been
happening to the hero society
is now being placed squarely on the
shoulders of the number one pro hero
endeavor as the number one pro hero
endeavor is the most visible face
of the hero society and so in the eyes
of the public
he is the most responsible for keeping
the peace
just as all might was before his
retirement but
now that the hero society is falling
apart and the villains are rampaging
throughout japan
and after what dobby publicly revealed
about endeavor
the japanese public is furious with the
number one
pro hero clearly endeavor is no
almight he is no symbol of peace and if
the number one pro hero is
this flawed and this unreliable then
what can we expect from the rest of the
heroes
as the number one hero endeavour was the
public face of the hero society
and now he is also the public face of
the people's outrage
with that same society what's more
endeavor himself
is in really bad shape both physically
and
emotionally his physical health appears
to be stable he's obviously injured but
he's recovering
but mentally and emotionally he is a
completely
broken man back when he had faced off
against dabi
he completely froze up he simply could
not
fight his own son and he is now racked
with guilt about everything he had done
to dobby and to the rest of his family
in the past just like the hero society
as a whole the endeavor we knew
is dead this man is now a shadow of his
former self
and we see him actually crying as his
family comes to visit him
in the hospital as he cries endeavor
apologizes to his family
again and again but he knows that it's
too late now
he cannot take back the horrible things
that he has done
and dobby is living proof of that dobby
endeavour's own son has become a mass
murdering villain
and just like dobby's horrible actions
can never be taken back
so too endeavors treatment of his family
can't be taken
back the damage is done and the
consequences have been catastrophic
especially when we look at what dobby
has become but
then to endeavour's great surprise rey
enters his hospital room behind the
children
as endeavour asks why she is here rey
answers that she is here to talk about
their family and about toya
and that is how this chapter ends
wow what a crazy time to be an mha fan
and this really is a different kind of
story than it was when the series
first started now that rey has entered
the chat
i hope that we will learn more about
toya and how exactly he became
dobby we still don't know the specifics
we don't know how he ended up in that
fire and what happened to him after the
fire when everyone thought he was dead
i really want to know those details i
want to get the complete picture of
dobby's backstory so hopefully rey
will reveal those details to us in the
coming chapters
all in all the message of these last few
chapters has been
very clear the hero society as we know
it is
dead the my hero academia that we knew
up to this point
has come to an end and the era of peace
is over
as a new much darker era of chaos
arrives
this massive change in the world of boku
no hero is going to have a profound
impact on everyone and this includes all
of our favorite characters
deku will not be the same deku after
this ochoko will not be the same ochako
kirishima will not be the same kirishima
and so on these characters will need to
mature
and change very quickly and this really
feels
different i have a hard time imagining
the story going back to some sort of
light-hearted school festival arc
or tournament arc after this i
definitely don't see it happening
until this chaotic situation is brought
under control
but by the looks of it that won't be
happening anytime
soon definitely let me know what you
guys think did you enjoy
this chapter and do you think that the
hero society can
ever recover from all of this chaos
also what do you think that stain will
do
now will he continue hunting heroes
as he was doing before or will he
perhaps
start hunting the villains instead
finally
how do you think that deku bakugou and
the other heroes are going to change
in the aftermath of all of this chaos do
you think that they can ever go back to
being those
fun-loving hero students that they were
before this
insane war arc don't forget to share
your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this pokuno hero video and you
want to see more please leave a like
to let me know it really does help and
if you are new to anime out pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a ton of our videos even if you
are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
liam thompson al-jatal
dr cortman johnny boy draws emperor
otaku
spidey life canal baked buddhist and
tungsten tarcus
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky joe stanton
very gucci jessica calefon the rathune
d'aura alicia octa bonnie parks hinokami
and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you